There's some news out today
about how many jobs, or at
least a claim of how many jobs,
have been created so far
from the stimulus plan.
And at first, the numbers
look impressive.
The administration said that
650,000 jobs were created from
$150 billion of stimulus
spending so far.
So let me write that down.
So what does that turn out
to on a per-job basis?
Let's see, let's get a
calculator out here.
If I spent $150 billion to get
650,000 jobs-- let me just
divide by 650,000-- I get
to $230,000 per job.
So that is equal to $230,000
per job, which is
claimed to be saved.
So obviously, they're not just
outright paying the salary,
these people were adding some
value to begin with.
So these were clearly
very good jobs.
So $230,000, I think it's fair
to say, is more than the
majority of us make.
So these are very good jobs.
Now, there's a further claim
that at least another 350,000
jobs were created from $189
billion of tax relief.
We got $189 billion less to
the government and that
created 350,000 jobs.
So let's see what that
turns out to be.
That's $189 billion
in tax relief.
Let's see what that is
on a per job basis.
Get the calculator out.
And so, if we have $189 billion,
so you divide that by
350,000 jobs.
And you get $540,000 per job.
So this is equal to $540,000 per
job, which are even better
than the $230,000 jobs
that we were able to
save with $150 billion.
So clearly some very highly paid
people are being able to
keep their jobs by virtue
of the stimulus package.